welcome back to Modern Agri machines
today we're diving into the fascinating
world of onion farming from planting to
harvest and finally to processing let's
see how onions make their way from the
field to your plate let's get started
onions are grown worldwide with the
largest producers being China India and
the United States these countries
cultivate millions of tons annually
providing iding a massive contribution
to the global economy not only are
onions crucial for flavor and cooking
but they are also packed with essential
nutrients like vitamins B and
C in fact onions bring immense economic
value to Farmers generating billions in
Revenue they're also a nutritional
Powerhouse known to reduce the risk of
heart disease and improve immune
function the process of growing onions
begins with selecting seeds nurturing
seedlings and taking care of young
plants
before they are transplanted into the
fields for large scale cultivation the
seeds need to be treated to enhance
their germination rate and resistance to
pests before sewing the seeds are
typically soaked in warm water for 12 to
24 hours to stimulate germination after
treatment the seeds are sewn in seed
trays or directly into Nursery soil
onions grow best in loose well- drained
soil that is rich in organic matter
after preparing the soil Farmers plant
the seeds or onion bulbs in carefully
arranged rows watering is a crucial
factor for healthy onion growth drip
irrigation is commonly used to conserve
water and ensure optimal plant
development once onions are growing they
need constant care Farmers regularly
weed the fields to prevent competition
for nutrients and use organic
fertilizers to enhance growth onions are
also vulnerable to pests like onion
thrips in diseases such as Downey mildew
many farmers adopt organic or
chemical-free PES control methods to
ensure healthy safe crops after 90 to
150 days onions reach maturity when the
tops of the onions fall over it's time
to harvest Farmers carefully pull or
lift onions from the ground to prevent
damage in smaller Farms harvesting is
done by hand but for larger operations
specialized machines make the process
quicker and more efficient
[Music]
once harvested onions are sorted by size
and quality in modern processing plants
conveyors and automatic sorters are used
to speed up the process after sorting
they are cleaned and packaged ready to
be shipped to markets worldwide thanks
to modern technology the entire process
is more efficient ensuring the freshest
onions for consumers from large scale
Farms to your local grocery store onions
play a huge role in the economy and our
daily diets they affordability and
health benefits make them a staple food
around the world that's all for today's
video on onion farming from growing and
caring for the crops to harvesting and
processing we've covered every step if
you found this video helpful don't
forget to like subscribe and hit the
notification Bell for more insights in
into modern agricultural practices
thanks for watching modern Agro machines
we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]